[音楽]
ブーバー仕切っ難しい
ブーバーし
ちょっと r だ後をザシューズでねあれあっ大きい
あと聞いたこれというのは混合聞いちゃったから
ああああああ
あああっああ4泊しかーしっに
あーあとプログラムフェイスブッだからこれすごいよね選択者が知事店来てたみたい
です
はぁんっ
こんにちははじめしそうです2018年1月
皆さんは年始め何をしますか一連の最初は
鬼没を切り替えたいそういう方多いと思います僕はことスイッチネジ物を切り替える
ために今
ブーツ
[音楽]
福森らー
かなり1年の最初誰しもの気持ちを切り替えたいと思うんですけども
もうなんか服上下なゆかさん以下に作ったことあるんですけども今回はかなりの服を
売ろうと思います
顔1回ちょっと全部出してみましょうガストありすぎるんですよねだか選択も埋まって
きてないし服が追ってきてなんかどれ木でいいんだろう
中間な加工脱ぎ散らかしなんかから腹パンになっちゃう
プレイズボンなんか5万円くらいあればいいかなくらいの気持ちでそれ以外の風塗る
ことにしました貰い物でもね心が痛むんですけどやっぱ断捨離ってそういうことなん
ですよ
やばい守護霊がエグいいか
全振ります
これは大変だったって本当に1南家辛くというか考えてみましょ
[音楽]
またこれ履けそうだな吐きそうだ
んけそうこれはちょっと囲っ
[音楽]
倉敷たことがある感が凄い
このバカ俺は服にもれちまう服にもれちゃうんでちょっと本当にまずで断捨離っていう
かもう心を鬼にして売っております
[音楽]
が昔着てたなぁ26まあこれも音が昔聞いた気がするな
オタクが無事がそれがきっ
[音楽]
技がこれもメッツ昔着てた気がする
はまあなんか来たことある気がする一時期気が狂ったようにボーダーの福祉できません
でしたからね
まじこれもなんかめっちゃ昔から来てますよ
見たことある人多いと思いますこれうりライフ
[音楽]
選択したら知事みせちゃいました
うわーこレモネードめちゃくちゃきてた気がします昔
フリマ
塗るのかなこれ本当に売る
よりねああオリバーさん美食の
見たくないん
売りまーす
male
ずっと来て別だときてずっと人だよずっと着て出た
ルールフルを
続の動画のエンディング出来てる青いジャケットですね
おいでではもう
俺は彼はるって決めたんだよもうすごいこの中に来てもらいものを取った僕がすごい
めちゃくちゃ気に入ってたものとはたくさんあるんですけど上は名前これはちょっと
思い出が深すぎる a これ重いですか
グロットああ
[音楽]
これで5年前に僕鑑定ですめっちゃ気に入ってて
このなんか変な貝殻みたいなのが付いているのが押されたなって思ってた時期があり
ました
売ります振っ靴下ウェルネスは
me
ああああああ
うーんすごいあそれに10万円20万円に10万円20万円20万これで100倍の服
さらにプラスでこのコートと僕がここ23年作ってきた江川っぽいジャケット
[音楽]
ブーバーしか無いからなぁ
10柄のスター山ですねお母さんからダサいと言われたので売ることにしましただけで
ちょっとほんと結構
普段よく来てたような個まとめて撃っちゃうんでちょっと悲しいですけど
てこようと思います
tan
はっっ
[音楽]
ハイあの査定に1時間半かかりました
posh と僕がすぐ値段聞いちゃのち晴れだったんで友達にも行かせて友だちから
値段を聞こうと思いますし打者を待っちゃう
きたつきみなのでなの方は
入っちゃってですはい
値段が入っ
10,000うっ本当に
7,000410円で矢切ぐでー
[音楽]
me
ええええええ
バッハ
術たぞくねっと黒ね何がその売れたんだろうけど売れてますねなんか高いので見ると
3000円くらいのた俺が大切にしてたアウターハ
高く売れてる何枚かええーっ
いつも7000